buona sera io sono contento di essere
qui perché parlare in un antico e
prestigioso teatro e per me un onore ma
vi parlerò di cose molto innovative e
che ben si affiancano in realtà la
tradizione per me la transizione la
transizione per me è una transizione
energetica io mi occupo di energia ma
questo è il momento giusto per parlare
di una transizione energetica perché nel
giorno 4 di novembre entrerà in vigore
in tutto il mondo l'accordo di parigi
l'accordo di parigi può essere criticato
può non esserlo sicuramente bisogna
realizzarlo ma certo mentre vigore con
una velocità che è stata otto volte
quella del precedente protocollo di
kyoto
quindi qualcosa nel mondo si muove e io
diciamo ritengo che sia per fortuna
perché la temperatura del pianeta poi
magari ve ne parlerà qualcun altro dopo
di me la temperatura del pianeta è già
un sacco di tempo che aumenta fino a
livelli che non ci sono mai stati fino a
che noi siamo in grado di andare
indietro con le misure ma non vi parlerò
di questo io vi parlerò delle
alternative perché io di questo mi
occupo io mi occupo di un modello
energetico alternativo perché quando il
l'accordo di parigi sarà entrato in
vigore lo dovremo realizzare
ora io ho un modello energetico da
portare avanti intanto penso che non è
che ci si possa fidare più di tanto
degli dei governi e degli stati e che
noi dobbiamo avere una partecipazione la
partecipazione secondo me è quella che
ognuno di noi deve diventare auto
produttore di energia e scambiarla con i
vicini questo modello si chiama prossime
r's cioè produttori e consumatori di
energia allo stesso tempo ora è un
modello che in realtà si valuta che nei
prossimi dieci anni venti anni in europa
sarà assai diffuso
quindi io vi parlo di cose innovative di
cui magari non avete sentito parlare ma
si tratta di cose che prenderanno piede
assai presto
io ho una cosa in particolare da
aggiungere come è ovvio dal momento che
la mia fondazione si chiama the hydrogen
university perché noi dobbiamo dice io
devo parlare di idrogeno
ora a che serve di idrogeno l'idrogeno
serve
come energy sto legge che significa
accumulo di energia perché le energie
rinnovabili perché alla fine transizione
energetica che cosa significa
significa che noi dobbiamo uscire dal
mondo fossile così come lo abbiamo
conosciuto e dobbiamo andare alle
rinnovabili
allora guardate che le rinnovabili
quelle più diffuse il fotovoltaico
all'eolico anno tecnicamente diciamo
carattere discontinuo non programmabile
quindi siccome non lo possiamo
programmare se vogliamo uscire
completamente tali centrali tradizionali
abbiamo bisogno di accumulare energy
storage è una cosa importante secondo me
e pharrell energy store age con le
batterie
semplicemente non è investire loro e
allora secondo me la soluzione che io vi
propongo è quella dell'idrogeno
allora io non parlo solo di idrogeno
faccio cose questo mezzo che voi vedete
davanti al parlamento italiano
ma quel giorno attenzione quel giorno
dentro il parlamento italiano non
c'erano i soliti deputati ma c'erano
bensì tutti i presidenti di tutti i
parlamenti di europa e anche un po del
bacino del mediterraneo
noi siamo andati lì con il nostro mezzo
perché portiamo avanti il nostro
discorso e io ancora devo ringraziare la
presidente della camera che ce lo ha
consentito
certo che noi siamo stati lì con il
nostro mezzo e che cosa facciamo noi
facciamo educazione e facciamo
comunicazione è quello il nostro compito
perché poi alla fine se noi dobbiamo
parlare della transizione energetica
oltre a fare degli impianti
noi dobbiamo spiegare dobbiamo fare
comunicazione in questo momento lo sto
facendo e ringrazio chi mi ha invitato
ma certo io per venire qui ho preso un
paio di taxi e delle auto idrogeno i
tassisti bolognesi tra l'altro assai
precisi non sapevano assolutamente nulla
quindi la comunicazione è essenziale
come essenziale la formazione perché
alla fine queste tecnologie come tutte
le tecnologie ci metteranno 15 20 anni
per prendere piede
e allora noi dobbiamo formare sin da ora
le giovani generazioni perché se la
giovane generazione come ora voi sapete
bene sono assai più alfabetizzate di noi
dal punto di vista
diciamo dell'utilizzo dei computer dei
degli smartphone eccetera
allora allo stesso modo dovranno essere
più svelti di noi sa usare le nuove
tecnologie bene ma le nuove tecnologie
che cosa comportano le nuove tecnologie
con palco il mezzo sempre posso
mostrarvi alcune immagini del mezzo
eccolo che entra nella nostra sede e
questo si apre questo si apre a farfalla
e ha un tetto fotovoltaico
ecco poi a una sala multimediale al
seguito questo è un concerto dentro la
sala questo camion si apre e diventa una
sala che eccola lì c'è una stampante 3d
a bordo ecco un autovettura modifica in
grado di rifornire delle autovetture
eccolo attrezzato a studio televisivo
questo mezzo ecco che sensibilizzo un
priore anche la chiesa cattolica
questi qui che questi qui non so perché
l'ho trovato e comico però
questi altri invece sono una delegazione
cinese a bordo del mezzo
la persona con gli occhiali con cui sto
parlando ci ha invitato a shanghai ea
fare il tour della cina con il nostro
mezzo per cui noi ora che ci accingiamo
a fare il tour dell'europa con il nostro
veicolo
siamo già invitati anche in cina quindi
questo mezzo farà il suo mestiere ma io
ora diciamo oltre a mostrarvi ecco mi
fermo su quest'ultima immagine questa
ultima immagine questa fuel cell cella
combustibile non l'ho fatta io e
industriale non dirò chi perché insomma
dovevo farlo allora a questo punto però
il la cella a combustibile
badate bene quella è la mia mano cioè
questa cella sarà e grosso come un
piccolo computer e peserà 10 15 kg
attenzione che quelli sono 100 kilowatt
quella cella è l'elemento della
transizione energetica della prossima
rivoluzione energetica addirittura le
macchine che utilizzano celle di questo
tipo hanno già ce l'hanno già un tasto
social mode per cui uno parcheggia la
macchina nel garage spingere social mode
utilizza l'idrogeno che può essere
quello che si porta a bordo ma anche un
tubicino di un idrogenodotto eccetera
e allora da 100 kilowatt alla rete che
in casa ce ne avrete 6 massimo per cui
un palazzo
questo è in grado di rifornire un
palazzo durante le soste
quindi è il mondo al contrario ma non è
l'unica cosa noi con l'idrogeno con le
tecnologie a idrogeno possiamo
organizzare un altro mondo ed è quello
che io diciamo sono impegnato a fare
allora noi con l'idrogeno abbiamo questa
è una autovettura delle emissioni
totalmente pulite che significa che
questa macchina produce acqua distillata
e neanche la semina per strada c'è un
tasto
la scarica quando uno per i premi un
tasto quindi noi abbiamo emissioni zero
e il ciclo e il ciclo dell'acqua
allora io diciamo sì come probabilmente
vi fanno delle domande
adesso interrompo la mia conferenza e vi
ringrazio di avermi ascoltato
no perché lui è proprio così è ieri con
molta umile nonchalance mi dice no fai
perché io ho praticamente messo suo
inventato questo mezzo
questa station energy l'hai chiamata che
produce idrogeno ma nello stesso tempo
si alimenta ed è unica al mondo c'è
questa cosa è assolutamente così
e quello che ho fatto negli ultimi 22
presenze si fa tutti i giorni si svegli
al mattino è ok allora ti chiedevo
questo perché in italia c'è difficoltà a
utilizzare le auto ad idrogeno si l'auto
che ho mostrato in italia non può
circolare che non sia a bolzano
perché non ci sono i distributori e non
c'è la normativa per le caratteristiche
tecniche che ora non voglio diciamo
descrivere però c'è bisogno di una
normativa che ora a dire la verità
proprio in questo periodo diciamo sta
passando una direttiva europea che
passerà il 18 di novembre
lo stato italiano si è preso un anno per
mettere a posto la normativa certo se
facessero un po prima sarei più contento
però in italia noi abbiamo un problema
di normativa e abbiamo un problema poi
di punti di rifornimento
quindi noi avremmo bisogno di una catena
di distribuzione come è possibile
rifornisce che so di metano dovrà essere
possibile rifornirsi il rock perfetto ha
risposto anche ad altra domanda che cosa
fatta fare il governo per andare in
questa direzione ma se si può fidare
ok grazie a mille grazie dolce buonasera